I remember our coach he didn't just say
this to me he said that to others he
said the easiest thing you can do in
life is quit and this ties into
everything it's like I don't know it
kind of It kind of burns because it's
like are you just gonna quit but that's
easy you're gonna take the easy way out
okay there's something special about it
because it's like it's it's very
encouraging encouraging but like you're
gonna really take the easy way out huh
no you just quit yeah just quit like
everyone else and it's like so since
we're being this world is becoming so
soft and people give up so easily if
you're willing to just keep going you
will stand out and have such an
unbelievable advantage over everybody
and it's only getting worse because
everyone whether it's having this victim
mentality and people quitting so easily
[Music]